Are Cell Phones Safe?
I do not have a house phone.
Instead, I use a cell phone.
My question is, how safe are cell phones?
I heard that cell phones can make a man infertile.
If they can do that, what else can they do?
Come on, I deserve an explanation.
You work for a cell phone company, so you must know something.
Explain to me how it works and stuff please, Lynn!
Well, just by their basic operation,...
...cell phones emit a small amount of electromagnetic radiation.
There's a lot of talk in the news these days...
...about whether or not cell phones emit enough radiation to cause adverse health effects.
The concern is that cell phones are often placed close to or against the head during use,...
...which puts the radiation in direct contact with the tissues in the head.
In this position, there is a good chance that some of the radiation will be absorbed by human tissue.
If you are worried about the potential hazards of cell phone radiation,...
...there are some ways to reduce your risk,...
...such as using a hands-free headset, among others.